autopsie d'une intelligence artificielle
documentaire réalisé par Jean-Christophe
ribbaau un film vous venez de le voir
qui s'est attaché à décrypter les
réalités qui se cachent derrière l' en
abordant son fonctionnement mais aussi
les défis auxquels sont confrontés les
scientifiques et les questions éthiques
que pose son utilisation alors quelles
sont les principales questions que
soulève désormais l'omniprésence de
l'intelligence artificielle dans notre
société nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de dbadoc aujourd'hui mir
mjoubi pour commencer est avec nous
bienvenue à vous vous êtes ancien
secrétaire d'État chargé du numérique
sous les gouvernements d'Édouard
Philippe et ancien député la République
en marche de Paris vous êtes aujourd'hui
entrepreneur en mettant justement le cap
sur l'intelligence artificielle
Guillaume Gralet est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste du domaine qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui au sein de l'h
hebbdomadaire le point le point qui sort
ce guide le guide de l'intelligence
artificielle et alors on lit les
sous-titres he comment en tirer parti
dans son métier c'est une vraie question
on en parlera tout à l'heure et app puis
travail cuisine sport loisirs éducation
santé trois petits points notre
sélection dites-vous d'outils pour se
faciliter la vie grâce à l'intelligence
artif en tier vraiment le meilleur ouais
de manière assez simple c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de de faire et en fait ça peut
être accessible à tous ben c'est ce
qu'on va essayer de voir avec vous et on
va faire en sorte justement que cette
question soit accessible à tous et on va
le faire également avec vous Catherine
Tessier bienvenue vous êtes directrice
de recherche ingénieur experte à l'ONERA
alors l'ONA c'est l'office national
d'études et de recherche aérospatiale
vous êtes membre du groupe d'experts
adhoc de l'UNESCO en vue de
l'élaboration d'un instrument sur
l'éthique de l'intelligence artificielle
et puis on vous doit cet ouvrage
collectif intitulé pour une éthique du
numérique un ouvrage que vous avez
coordonné au côté d'Éric Germain et
Claude de Kirchner et c'est ce livre est
disponible aux éditions des presses
universitaires de France première
question après avoir vu ce documentaire
question toute simple mais commençons
par le commencement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner une définition simple
compréhensible par tous de ce qu'est
l'intelligence artificielle bien
l'intelligence artificielle la première
chose qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est ce
n'est pas une intelligence qu' sera qui
serait artificiel c'est une discipline
scientifique alors c'est difficile à à
séparer du vocable intelligence
artificielle voilà quand on parle de
mathématique ou de géologie on voit bien
que ce sont des disciplines
scientifiques l'intelligence
artificielle on a tendance à
anthropomorphiser la chose donc on lit
l'intelligence artificielle fait ceci ou
cela ou des intelligences artificielles
sont mis en œuvre pour bon ouais euh
alors l'intelligence artificielle existe
depuis longtemps hein puis puisque
depuis les années 50 et pendant
longtemps donc ce sont des programmes si
ça des programmes informatiques et
initialement ces programmes étaient
conçus pour réaliser des démonstrations
mathématiques ou faire du raisonnement
donc imiter finalement simuler le
raisonnement humain et puis donc plus
récemment avec le le développement
surtout des grands de la disponibilité
des grandes masses de données euh
d'autres types de programmees alors basé
plus sur les probabilités les
statistiques les
corrélations sont mis en œuvre pour
trouver en fait des similarités dans ces
grandes masse de données et c'est ce qui
a donné lieu à la sortie donc
relativement récente fin 2022 22 des
système d'intelligence artificielle
générative donc qui peuvent enfin qui
simulent la réponse à des questions d'un
utilisateur en particulier alors ça
c'était votre définition hein de
l'intelligence artificielle j'en ai
trouvé d'autres autre elles sont chaque
fois un peu différentes j'ai retenu par
exemple celle du Conseil de
l'Europe l'intelligence artificielle dit
le Conseil de l'Europe est un ensemble
de sciences théories et techniques dont
le but est de reproduire par une machine
des capacités cognitives d'un être
humain et puis pour le Parlement
européen l'intelligence artificielle
représente tout outil utilisé par une
machine afin je je cite de reproduire
des comportements liés aux humains tels
que le raisonnement la planification et
la créativité ça rejoint tout même
évidemment c'est normal hein c'est ce
que vous venez de dire repr reproduire
ou pas parce que fouiller dans un
ensemble énorme de données et y trouver
des similarités ou des des choses que
l'esprit humain n'est pas capable
d'appréhender lui-même donc on voit
qu'on ne simule pas l'esprit humain mais
que voilà on apporte quelque chose
d'autre finalement on va essayer de
comprendre l'étendue des champs
d'application de l'intelligence
artificielle dans une récente interview
au magazine Capital vous disiez m mjoubi
les besoins sont infinis mes dernières
expériences m'ont convaincu que ce que
nous vivons depuis 1 an constitue un
changement radical de paradigme pour
notre économie et pour la société donc
les champs d'application semblent
immenses immense massif mais on en a
connu d'autres mais je pense que ce
changement qu'on est en train de vivre
est encore plus important que tous les
précédents on est quelquesuns ici à
avoir plus de 40 ans c'est enfin mon cas
et on a connu l'air avant Internet avant
l'ordinateur à la maison et on se
souvient tous de ce qui s'est passé
ensuite enfin quand j'étais petit à la
banque il y avait le papier carbone
ensuite aujourd'hui on a l'application
on fait tout à distance on a chez nous
des ordinateurs qui sont tout petits
mais qui ont la capacité de calcul de ce
qu'on avait avant dans des maisons
entières ou dans des immeubles entiers B
ben ça ça a changé des secteurs de façon
incroyable le milieu bancaire
aujourd'hui ne peut pas fonctionner sans
l'informatique la recherche aujourd'hui
utilise des capacités de calcul très
importantes qui lui ont permis d'aller
extrêmement loin dans ce qu'elle est
capable de découvrir proposer construire
bah là avec l'intelligence artificielle
on est dans une révolution au moins
aussi grosse que celle d'Internet au
moins aussi grosse que le
micro-ordinateur on atteint aujourd'hui
grâce à la miniaturisation qui nous
permet d'avoir des capacités de calcul
inégalé à un traitement de données
inégalé et donc ce qui est capable de
faire intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui c'est tout ce qu'on
imaginait pourir faire avec
l'informatique x 1000 x 10000 et même
avec les nouvelles générations di à
générative des choses qu'on avait même
pas imaginé est-ce qu'on est dans cette
révolution ou simplement au début de
cette révolution dont vous parlez ben
c'est ce que vous venez de poser comme
question c'est celle du rythme et c'est
la plus importante c'est celle du rythme
et du retard et du danger du retard on
est en plein de dents certains disent
mais non on est très tôt certains disent
c'est déjà trop tard mais cela ils ont
dit ça de toutes les technologies la
grande question si regarde les
entreprises l'économie si je suis une
entreprise d'un secteur donné la santé
la recherche la défense une banque si
mes concurrents utilisent l'intelligence
artificielle mes concurrents étranger
notamment eux vont acquérir une avance
sur moi qui sera insurmontable pour moi
si je ne m'engage pas dès aujourd'hui
mais ça veut dire quoi une avance
insurmontable ça veut dire que je coule
c'estàd que je licencie tout le monde
parce que souvent on a peur des emplois
qui pourra être remplacé par
l'intelligence artificielle il viendra
d'ailleurs et pensez aux emplois qui
vont disparaître parce qu'on a pas saisi
le train de l'intelligence artificielle
imaginez 2 secondes que nos entreprises
françaises ne se transforment pas
aujourd'hui mais alors tous leurs
concurrents proposont des produits plus
intelligents plus utiles moins cher à
produire et tous nos emplois
disparaîtront et ce sera pas à cause de
l'intelligence artificielle chez nous ce
sera à cause de l'intelligence
artificielle chez les autres la
publication de ce
guide de votre magazine Le Point tant à
prouvver que cette intelligence
artificielle rentre dans notre quotidien
quand vous dites travail cuisine sport
loisir éducation partout euh vous pouvez
profiter de l'intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous nous dites
avec ce oui c'estàdire qu'il y a à la
fois ce constat de d'accélération he que
fait très bien Mounir c'est moi j'adore
l'expression qu'utilise Mustapha
Suleiman le co-créateur de Deep mind
deep mind vous savez he c'est cet
entreprise qui a battu les meilleurs
joueurs de Go au monde et qui récemment
ces dernières années a montré qu'il
étaient capable de modéliser le
repliement des protéines il nous
promettre de mettre au point des
nouveaux matériaux des nouveaux
médicaments donc on voit bien que ça
touche tout et Mustapha Souleiman parle
d'une desferland d'un tremblement de
terre et puis effectivement on peut
s'emparer effectivement de ces outils au
quotidien dès aujourd'hui lorsque vous
allez peut-être préparer une réunion je
trouve ça très intéressant à travers un
outil he qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
Copilot mais heureusement il y a
beaucoup d'autres concurrents dont on
parle dans ce hors série et bien vous
allez avoir un logiciel qui va vous
suggérer un un un thème un ordre du jour
en fonction de ce dont vous voulez
parler les personne invité il va vous
vous rédiger un email d'invitation avec
un ton plus ou moins détendu for il va
assister à la réunion il va faire un
compte-rendu de la réunion il va même
faire un résumé pour les personnes qui
arriv en retard vous dites certaines
questions qui ont été posées d'autres
qui n'ont pas encore été posées et donc
vous avez un un gain de temps assez
formidable il faut effectivement s'en
emparer je pense au plus vite parce que
ce n'est pas la machine qui risque de
remplacer l'homme mais ce sont les
hommes qui savent
dompter parler à la machine et surtout
en garder le contrôle j'espère qu'on en
parlera est-ce que vous avez envie de
mettre des réserves parce qu'il vient
d'être dire uninant euh oui si oui
lesquel
oui euh le le le le principe de gagner
du temps donc on pourrait se demander
pourquoi finalement l'être humain
cherche toujours à gagner du temps et
surtout pourquoi faire de ce temps qu'il
aura gagné euh ça c'est une bonne
question qui plus une question
philosophique d'ailleurs mais voilà
pourquoi cherche-t-on tout le temps à
gagner du temps euh et puis par ailleurs
donc vous évoquez le la question de la
Réunion qui serait préparée grâce à des
documents élaborés automatiquement des
contre-rendus qui serait automatiquement
et cetera qui ne seront peut-être
d'ailleurs jamais lu donc on peut se
poser la question la question de
finalement est-ce que un compte-rendu ou
un mémoire de fin d'étude voire un
mémoire de thèse généré en grande partie
automatiquement finalement en quoi ça
élève l'humain qui le qui le produit en
tant que sa propre
production
euh en quoi ça lui apprend quelque chose
et puis surtout s'il n'est pas lui
finalement à quoi tout ça sert-il hein
si on produit des documents automatiques
parce que c'est rébarbatif à faire et
que finalement personne ne les lit bon
on pourrait peut-être se dispenser
finalement de produire ces documents
j'ai vu qu'on parlait beaucoup
d'automatisation évidemment dans les
années 80 avec notamment la robotique il
s'agitaait de d'automatiser les les
process et aujourd'hui avec
l'intelligence artificielle on entrait à
autonomiser davantage les process c'est
c'est peut-être ça aussi la différence
dans l'application pratique de
l'intelligence artificielle alors un
objet rendre autonome des process un
objet un process un robot pas plus que
cette table ne sont autonomes au sens où
les l'être vivant et en particulier
l'être humain
euh donc on préférera dire d'un point de
vue scientifique qu'il s'agit toujours
d'automatiser des tâches par exemple
d'automatiser la production de texte
hein pour préparer sa réunion par
exemple mais en aucun cas un objet ne
peut être autonome entre Guillet
c'est-à-dire décider pour lui-même et se
fixer ses propres lois qui est la
définition de l'autonomie alors vous
l'avez évoqué grand fantasme autour de
l'emploi notamment est-ce que ça va
supprimer mon emploi aujourd'hui demain
est-ce que ça modifier le profil de de
l'emploi que j'exerce aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que semble-t-il que beaucoup de de
direction de ressources humaines se
préoccupe de ces questions pour
sensibiliser dès aujourd'hui hein les
les salariés des des entreprises j'ai
identifié moi trois secteurs dans
lesquels les choses risquent de de
changer assez rapidement le transport
notamment avec les véhicules autonomes
le domaine bancaire les services hein
d'une manière générale he les Chargers
clientèle les conseillers autour des des
services notamment dans le domaine de la
banque et puis la santé on l'a vu he
d'ailleurs dans ce documentaire où on
pourra céder avec des diagnostics et des
prescriptions jusqu'à la la robotisation
de certains actes médicaux on l'a très
bien vu dans dans ce film sont trois
secteurs semble-t-il les plus mise en
avant aujourd'hui dans les questions que
soulève l'intelligence artificielle vous
êtes d'accord ces secteurs là en
priorité vont vont être touché du point
de vue de l'emploi aujourd'hui ça va
changer la donne dans ces métiers ça va
changer la donne mais pas forcément au
détriment du nombre d'emploi et c'est ça
qui est important à avoir en tête si on
prend l'exemple du documentaire sur la
santé on voit surtout que les nouveaux
outils d'intelligence artificielle
proposé permett au médecin de proposer
des choses plus efficaces pour le
patient c'est-à-dire que le
l'utilisation massive de toutes les
images de tout l'historique des cancers
du sein va permettre aujourd'hui le
métier de cancérologue c'était déjà un
métier de statisticien c'était juste ils
apprenaient à identifier tous les
élément sur un cancer donné sur un
diagnostic donné pour essayer de
d'identifier le le le cancer spécifique
et le traitement qui va avec bah ça il
se trouve que l'intelligence
artificielle elle le fait plus vite de
façon plus correcte et de façon plus euh
utile qu'un être humain mais dans un
rendez-vous chez le médecin on va pas
devant un ordinateur on va pas faire une
mammographie tout seul on est malade on
a peur et la relation du soignant elle
est pas juste une relation de savoir
elle est une relation humaine et donc
imaginez votre soignant augmenter de son
intelligence artificielle il va vous
dire beaucoup plus de choses qui vont
être utiles pour vous et lui-même son
métier sera plus intéressant donc là sur
la santé on a que du progrès à recevoir
d'autres métiers qui sont plus inquié
qui doivent plus s'inquiéter et donc
plus se transformer encore plus rapid
rapidement les métiers de la
manipulation de l'information par
exemple un des grands cas connu en
France c'est ceux qui faisaient des
résumés de de de coupure de presse
chaque matin malheureusement
l'intelligence artificielle fait ça
mieux que des humains elle lit plus vite
et elle identifie plus rapidement les
sujets pour les mettre en page il se
trouve que cette tâche là depuis
longtemps elle est souvent outsourcée
comme on dit envoyée à l'étranger elle
était mal payée elle était difficile
mais les consultants en communication
ceux qui réfléchissent à comment
j'accompagne la parole du dirigeant
qu'est-ce que je l'aide à dire ceuxà ils
ont un avenir on aura toujours besoin de
gens pour nous aider à penser comment on
avance comment mais est-ce qu'on a
toujours besoin de gens pour résumer les
textes malheureusement je peux le dire
aujourd'hui si quelqu'un a pretté de
résumer des textes ça va être un peu
plus dur pour lui dans dans l'avenir
mais la future génération révolution qui
arrive c'est ce que vous avez rappelé
c'est la rencontre entre l'intelligence
artificielle et la robotique parce que
là on parle que des métiers
intellectuels mais les robots fins
précis avec de l'intelligence
artificielle vont pouvoir faire des
actes et on voit aujourd'hui des
simulations où ils vont vont avoir des
métiers de cariste automatisés ils vont
pouvoir manipuler dans des entrepôts
sans être humains derrière aujourd'hui
les entrepôts il représentent beaucoup
d'emplois et des emplois accessible à
beaucoup de monde si ces emplois
disparaissent va falloir réfléchir à
comment toutes ces personnesl elles
trouvent d'autres emplois mais encore
une fois on parle de transition que nous
avons connu et ces emploisl d'entrepôt
n'existaient pas il y a 10 ans parce que
nous ne faisions pas autant d'e-commerce
parce qu'il y avait pas autant de de de
plateformes en ligne donc on les a déjà
connu ces révolutions soyons prêts à les
affronter mais on en a er d'autres alors
la révolution industrielle ça concertait
ça concernait plutôt les emplois non
qualifiés or semble-t-il que cette
révolution pour reprendre ce terme
autour de l'intelligence artificielle
viserait davantage les les métiers
qualifiés aujourd'hui oui c'est-à-dire
qu'on a vu énormément de changements
actuel et à venir dans les métiers dit
créatif c'est-à-dire des métiers o on va
voir la machine qui va générer pour vous
des images des textes et puis
effectivement des vidéos alors de
manière de plus en plus rapide encore un
petit peu on voit encore beaucoup de
défaut mais mais mais ça change à la
vitesse de l'éclair effectivement vous
avez raison la la véritable question
c'est la position de l'homme face cette
accélération technologique qui constitue
plus ou moins une blessure narcissique
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit une machine sa
propre création le dépasser dans un
nombre croissant de de fonctions
cognitives alors il y a plusieurs
peut-être écueils à éviter le le premier
c'est la la crainte généralisée d'avoir
ce qu'on appelle une intelligence
artificielle générale c'est-à-dire
capable de battre l'homme sur dans
toutes ses fonctions cognitives ça je
pense qu'on n'est pas prêt d'y arriver
et c'est tant mieux euh comme une
machine consciente d'elle-même et et ça
il faut pas agiter trop trop de peur
mais c'est effectivement ce peut-être ce
syndrome j'adore cette expression hein
de du paléontologue Pascal pic ce
syndrome de la planète des singes
c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous voyez des
créatures quelquefois peut-être devenir
autant voir plus puissante que vous et
bien vous vous dites bon ben moi
j'arrête tout vous savez c'est le c'est
l'hippocampe hein du cerveau des euh des
taxis londoniens euh dont on voit qu'il
a diminué euh notamment euh parce que il
ne mémorise moins d'endroits avec euh la
montée en puissance de Waze il il faut
continuer à s'exercer à justement
peut-être exercer toutes ces ces
fonctions d'intuition de de de miser
d'avantage sur l'humain c'est ce qui
permettra sans doute à l'humain d'en
tirer le plus parti euh oui je voudrais
ajouter quelque chose de d'extrêmement
important c'est que ces programmes euh
ne comportent pas de sens de sémantique
et c'est ça l'apanage de l'humain c'est
qu'il met un sens dans les choses et un
sens dans sa pensée et cetera alors que
les programmes ne véhiculent aucun sens
ni aucune vérité donc en l'état actuel
de l'état de l'arbre faut jamais dire
jamais en science mais en l'état actuel
il faud il faut toujours l'être humain
pour donner un sens en particulier en
médecine pour interpréter ce que ce que
le résultat produit par par le programme
ou sur dans dans des recherches
scientifiques
quand le programme va va vous donner des
des références qui s'avèent fausses qui
n'existe pas ben c'est le chercheur
lui-même qui va par croisement des
sources et ça c'est indispensable
d'aller rechercher si vraiment le
résultat du programme est exact parce
que le programme n'est pas conçu pour
fournir une vérité ça n'est pas conçu
pour ça donc l'être humain lui il il a
une idée de ce que c'est que la vérité
ou des vérités en tout cas et en tout
cas lui il projette un sens depuis qu'il
est enfant il projette un sens sur les
choses ce que fa pas un prog j'observe
que quand on parle de ce sujet on se
rassure toujours en disant mais derrière
l'intelligence artificielle il y a
toujours un humain hein bien entendu
c'est peut-être quelque chose qu'il faut
toujours avoir en tête peut-être pour a
beaucoup de
fantasmes effectivement un chat GPT
effectivement est idiot ne compren pas
du tout même si il peut nous
impressionner ce qu'il est en train
d'écrire euh et même si encore une fois
l'interaction peut être très riche très
amusante euh il y a une expression qui
est très intéressante c'est celle qui a
été reprise hein par le chercheur
Jean-Gabriel Gana qui compare chat GPT
un perroquet stochastique c'est-à-dire
que il va euh absorber énormément de
contenu et puis il va jouer en réalité
sur les probabilité pour vous donner
quelque chose dont vous avez
l'impression qu'il a du sens la
véritable question et là je n'ai
absolument aucune réponse on va voir ce
que va dire la recherche plus tard c'est
est-ce qu'on pourra doter les machines
d'un lien avec l'extérieur on sait que
par exemple un bébé euh apprend beaucoup
en se faisant mal en bah en touchant
quelque chose qui est chaud par exemple
ça lui peut lui donner le sens commun
les machines en sont totalement
dépourvues peut-être qu'un jour elles en
auront un et là effectivement on devra
vivre dans un nouveau paradigme alors
chat GPT hein je vais je vais tout de
même rappeler ce que c'est hein c'est un
générateur de textes euh qui est capable
de rédiger des dissertations des poèmes
des traductions des des lettres hein
quel qu'elle soit un CV et autres et ce
système comm ceux qui sont capablees de
créer des sons et et des images ont été
révélé au grand public il y a assez peu
de temps hein ça c'est un des marqueurs
hein de la Révolution dont on parle et
on parle demain de parce qu'il s'agit de
les renseigner bien bien entendu et chap
GPT plus mieux il est renseigné plus la
réponse est
bluffante il y aurait même un métier à
venir qui serait de qui serait un
ingénieur jab GPT si je schématise un
petit peu qui serait dont le métier
serait de renseigner au plus près pour
avoir la réponse la plus précise
possible à la problématique posée on en
est là on est là dans sa dernière
version la version 4 on atteint un tel
niveau impressionnant qu'on pense qu'il
est plus intelligent qu'il ne l'est mais
tout de même il comprend le langage il
il enfin il le comprend il traduit ce
que l'humain écrit mais y compris dans
sa plus grande inexactitude pendant très
longtemps quand on voulait interroger
une machine il fallait l'interroger de
façon parfaite si vous saviez pas écrire
des lignes de côe c'estàdire le code
c'est une question parfaite avec un
langage parfait qui est compris de façon
parfaite par par l'ordinateur avec des
zé et des1 et qui répond là vous allez
pouvoir parler avec toute l'imperfection
de ce que vous êtes et si vous avez en
plus un handicap de langage ou que vous
ne parlez pas la langue du pays vous
pouvez lui dire à peu près les choses et
vous allez lui l'interroger sur ça et
vous allez recevoir une réponse très
intéressante on a vu sur des enfants qui
ont des troubles dyslexique par exemple
être capable de dire avec leurs mots et
avec leurs troubles et demander à chat
GPT d'écrire ce texte à la façon de un
courrier officiel et là c'est formidable
c'est vous avez une personne qui était
handicapée avant qui a formulé avec les
quelques mots qu'elle avait et par
approche de la moyenne par approche
statistique chat GPT va produire ce
texte à la façon du cy qu'on lui a donné
je trouve que ça c'est très utile c'est
très imp impressionnant et après il faut
voir ce qu'on en fait et aujourd'hui sur
Chat GPT et c'est dans votre journal
vous parlez de cuisine
une des choses que je fais en ce moment
c'est toutes les recettes que j'aime je
lui demande qu'il me les traduise en
recette végétarienne je dis trouve-moi
cette recette de tajine que j'aime
beaucoup là et fais en- mooi une recette
équilibrée végétarienne ben ce qui en
sort est très utile à ma famille j'en
suis très heureux est-ce que ça va
révolutionner le monde peut-être pas
mais en entreprise vous pouvez lui
demander de vous aider à produire des
mails j'ai vu une assistante sociale qui
me disait moi j'écoute des gens toute la
journée je dois produire des mails
administratifs toute la longueur de
journée bah la partie production mail
administratif je la fais avec chat GPT
sans prévenir mon employeur et écouter
les gens bah là je le fais avec mon cœur
chat GPT je peux peut-être conseiller à
ceux qui nous regardent d'essayer s'ils
l'ont pas encore fait parce que c'est ça
leur donnera une idée très concrète de
ce que du résultat que ça peut qu'on
peut obtenir avec avec cette
intelligence artificiel néanmoins tout
ce qu'on vient de dire là c'est sans
doute formidable pour l'avenir il y a
des côtés des volets form pour notre
avenir néanmoins ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes à commencer par des
problèmes éthiques moi je voudrais
savoir quels sont les problèmes éthiques
sur lesquels on bute aujourd'hui et les
les les questions éthiques qui se posent
autour de ce formidable développement de
l'intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui
bah il y en a un qui est un petit peu
évident et qui touche de plein fou bien
sûr les artistes les scénaristes les les
journalistes et c'est c'est le problème
des droits d'auteur comme comme vous
l'avez bien dit chat GPT sera d'autant
plus pertinent qu'il a été bien nourri
he si on si on on se permet cette
expression c'est-à-dire que la la
pertinence de ses réponses dépend de la
qualité et bien des contenus qu'il a pu
ingérer qui va lui permettre d'être
d'être pertinent dans un très grand
nombre de langues c'est ça qui est très
important et pour l'instant on voit mal
ben comment les il y a tout un un procès
he qui a intenté le New York Times à
open donc la maison m de chat GPT en lui
disant vous êtes entraîné sur nos
contenus nous on veut être rémunéré
inversement on a vu le groupe Accel
Springer nous un accord avec le même
open donc on voit mal encore aujourd'hui
et bien comment les les fournisseurs de
contenu seront rémunérés on a ce qu'on
appelle les watermark c'est-à-dire des
des des des des traces hein que qui
doivent permettre de remonter au
fournisseurs de contenu mais on voit
bien qu'il y a encore beaucoup de
challenge technologique à relever autre
problématique et on en parlera avec vous
c'est quand même votre spécialité mais
c'est c'est la protection des données
bien sûr hein parce que l'intelligence
artificielle se nourrit de
de de données et donc la protection des
données individuel revient au devant de
la scène avec l'intelligence
artificielle oui et on a vu
effectivement une autorité italienne
arrêter interdire quelques semaines chat
GPT parce qu'effectivement euh il y
avait un non respect des données vous
pouvez très facilement ça c'est
peut-être un un écueil en tout cas euh
comme vous avez l'impression de parler à
un ami vous allez vous confier hein il y
a des des personnalités de Samsung qui
qui ont qui ont qui se sont exprimés
avec chat GPT qui ont révélé des des
secrets industriels de l'entreprise qui
ont été malheureusement punis pour cela
c'est effectivement euh très très
important de savoir où vous donné vos
conversations h alors problème d'éthique
vous êtes en plein dedans ça fait partie
de votre domaine de recherche et de
votre expertise quels sont les problèmes
éthiques sur lesquels aujourd'hui il y a
urgence à travailler pour un temps soit
peu canaliser les mffet éventuels de
l'intelligence artificielle alors les
les les questions éthiques il y en a
énormément euh donc quand on s'intéresse
à aux questions éthiques liées au
numérique euh on s'intéresse d'abord à
voir queles sont les les valeurs qui
sont mises en jeu et en quoi ces valeurs
mais pourraient être pourrai être
affecté donc par ces ces nouveaux outils
et est-ce qu'il y a des tensions qui
apparaissent entre les valeurs la valeur
de l'autonomie humaine en particulier il
me semble qu'elle est enfin il nous
semble au comitéthique du numérique qu'
qu'elle est essentielle à
préserver et quand on a des outils qui
paraissent si formidables
on peut s'interroger et qui vont nous
aider dans nos métiers dans nos vie
qutidiennne et cetera on peut se poser
la question mais que va-t-il en être de
l'autonomie humaine c'est-à-dire de la
faculté de l'être humain à pouvoir
décider en
conscience et par
lui-même de faire telle ou telle chose
en particulier dans des situations
importantes où la décision est
importante autre critère que l'autonomie
humaine l'objet d'un observation précise
sur le plan éthique oui donc on parlait
tout à l'heure de la la protection des
données à caractère personnel alors vous
suggériez à nos à nos téléspectateurs de
d'essayer chat GPT la prière ou l'ont
pas faitou s rendra beaucoup plus
concret ce qu'on s'est dit sur ce
plateau la première chose qu'il faut
faire c'est de s'inscrire auprès deopi
qui est une société privée américaine en
donnant son numéro de téléphone et son
adresse mail donc on transfère donc à
cette société nos données à caractère
personnel qui permettent de nous
identifier absolument direct donc il
faut quand même le savoir bien sûr c'est
pas bien sûr le seul outil numérique qui
qui qui nous trace mais s'en est un de
plus voilà et par ailleurs comme vous
l'avez très justement mentionné
lorsqu'on va émettre des requêtes à ce
genre d'outil et bien plus ou moins on
va parler de nous et c'est-à-dire que
indirectement on va parler peut-être de
sa vie des éléments de sa vie privée
vous avez parlé de tajine tout à l'heure
et bien c'est un élément de votre vie
privée bien entendu autant que la liste
de mes recherches Google dernières
années absolument non mais absolument
peut-tre même plus inquiétante que ce
que je dis à chat GPT donc les données à
caractère personnel euh ça c'est ça
c'est alors si on va en dehors de chat
GPT sur les systèmes de reconnaissance
faciale par exemple qui vont qui eux
aussi exploite un nombre important de
données y compris toutes les photos que
l'on met de nous-même sur sur le web là
aussi c'est quelque chose à regarder
c'est-à-dire un système de
reconnaissance faciale très performant
c'est-à-dire qui identifierait
parfaitement la personne c'est génial
d'un point de vue technique mais on peut
se poser la question d'un point de vue
éthique c'estàdire quelque chose qui
reconnaît parfaitement les gens et sans
erreur et puis sur le plan législatif
c'est pas passé
inaperçu dans le secteur qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui il y a tout de même
cette législation européenne qui qui va
voir le jour si tout va bien en tout cas
tout le monde a l'air d'accord sur un un
texte
aujourd'hui c'est l'intelligence
artificielle acte européen c'est Thierry
Breton qui est qui est à la manœuvre qui
le le commissaire européens français sur
cette question ça va permettre quoi
cette législation européenne ça va
untant soit peu canalyser les choses les
contrôler concernant l'intelligence
artificielle la première c'est ne pas
être en retard la deuxième c'est être
réaliste ne pas être en retard c'est
permettre l'émergence d'acteurs
européens permettre la recherche
européenne sur le sujet permettre à des
acteurs à la fois de base mais des
acteurs appliquer de d'émerger sur le
sur sur le domaine et contrôler protéger
mais de façon réaliste et donc ce que
propose les ACT et qui est je pense la
chose la plus importante et je pense que
tous les pays du monde et toutes les
régions du monde nous copieront en
fonction des usages et des risques une
législation et une des règles
différentes
sur un moteur de génération de texte qui
utilise des bases de données anonymes
qui utilise du contexte du contenu
Internet après il se pose la question du
copyright mais hors copyright qui
utilise massivement des données text il
y a peu de choses à contrôler on fait
attention on applique les mêmes règles
qu'on a appliqué aux autres géants du
numérique données personn protection
donné personnelles pas de partage
consentement et cetera après maintenant
si on monte un peu plus haut utilisation
massive de données par des outils
d'intelligence artificielle pour des
prises de décisions lié à la défense ah
c'est autre chose et ben là on va les
contrôler comme on faisait avec les
autres outils de défense ENF tous nos
grands acteurs industriels aujourd'hui
qui font des bombes qui font des outils
autonomes d'avion de guerre ils sont
contrôlés par nos armées ils sont
contrôlés par nous tous et ben ce sera
pareil avec lia mais faut pas qu'on
utilise le contrôle
des objets militaires pour des Yas du
quotidien merci ce sera le le mot de la
fin hein c'est court on sera resté
encore un long moment avec vous he pour
parler de des problématiques soulevées
par le développement impressionnant he
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire de de
l'intelligence artificielle vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag dbatoc à
mon avis elle risque d'être nombreuse
sur le sujet merci à Salma s Sarah
udeline qui comme elle accoutumée m'ont
aidé à préparer cette émission et je
vous donne tout simplement rendez-vous
pour un prochain débad dooc avec bien
entendu son documentaire et son débat à
très
[Musique]
bientôt